Oh Colin Quinn hello Colin what Colin
Quinn do it on the phone holy moly I
call because I knew your rich boss on
and I wanted to compliment oh good huh
nothing as none of this negativity one
say something positive for a change
yeah it's needed well I just think that
when he's for sixtieth birthday party I
don't think anybody else would have came
up with such a groundbreaking original
ideas to have a rope yeah it is pretty
out of the box but think boss
I can crush you in these ropes I never
left of you whatever is left you
destroyed I love the colors excited
about the road I call out to start
smashing boss now Mama's gonna turn his
set from the Roche into a one-man show
nothing okay my DA might do it Colin D
College my favorite comic Wow like
favorite Colin are you excited about the
roast I am a look at the lineup list a
list all the way to a list can people go
to this singers it's all people that we
all sold a hundred tickets and go via
Beck sold without announcing who's on
the rows well I didn't ye why can I sell
hundred tickets because there's not
going to be enough room for all the
comics and Industry and everybody that's
in danger in what Ringo Street say about
people leaving Netflix has shown us a
diverse industry had like if you give a
[ __ ] a vendor's people coming from coke
and Dow industry oh wow okay that's okay
I'm just amazed at Colin called in I'm
starstruck well the idea that he would
give you believe this [ __ ] idiot
saves a hundred industry tickets for his
own room shut up
thanks for calm first why did put this
together use the industry these other
comics and industry industry stinks are
the worst audiences
yep I'm sure comics vertigo comic
cylinders how many comics they should be
a hundred comics showing up get to the
other words even shows how stupid she is
she's
the cooling the knowledge I need 100
industry seats no yelling you [ __ ]
idiot Kazakh Sam you're getting two
comics and guess is it take it could you
say three before you did makes any
industry yeah I hear agency already
Netflix are [ __ ] line up Netflix
wants eight tickets HBO ones for should
I make a series out of this show times
probably researching for that stand-up
show that they're doing alright and how
they all going to be just the
conversation justly gravity of the
conversation to two of them and that's a
little curve that curve right before you
get to the Lincoln Tunnel
well how many see should we say well
I'll be honest with you I say 75 because
let's make it a hundred and Union them
and you're right they're curve for $95
the 495 seelix they're worth the seven
the hell reserved for three hurts
everyone oh yeah everyone have their own
tell you a has a table uh hundred
tickets for industries no are you in
common what I put 25 there's going to be
that it would be almost a give Abul
there's no these people they're
[ __ ] if they come it doesn't mean
anything
there's one open I'll talk about the
Phoenix because there's already hurt a
person a hundred tickets you're not no
comic nobody's interested is what what
he's not a comet a mommy oh yeah that
you're not a comics kind of a kidding me
nobody's dentures when I'm on the road
they flock in from the [ __ ] although
exactly because you're a road hacks road
you give hope to give every horrible
in the country [ __ ] good all right
was that good oh [ __ ] yes I could say
I'm alright guys make [ __ ] killing me
you gotta go you gotta go
I'm very glad I called even though the
girl on the phone I was trying to be
funny with it I go I'm like say
something positive about rich boss she
was over two names I hit with the
punchline I thought you like oh I go
Colin quenchless okay Colin honey's but
she had no idea what was yeah no rest
for the public
who's the lineup for the row who's here
doing the roast who's on the loose I
mean it was on the dais Norton Bobby
that's three at that College Bobby
Collins Florentine Bonnie's a host funny
show host Florentine Judy gold
DeRosa big J and Luis Gomez and Annie
Lederman oh I forgot Louis and Annie oh
that is gonna be a good roast
keith is on the website too now season
on Heath bailed okay that's why we got
Louis that fell for racial reasons yes
so we got a you know we put Louis on to
get close as close as we could but if
you can get yeah you sure you don't to
just pull a few of the hundred comics
out of the audience to see if they want
to come up and television yeah huh no
calm I'm saying what you said I'm in an
industry exactly and guess shut up it's
going to be two comics and [ __ ] each
have 48 guests so have your husband
Ricky I guarantee this place is going to
be sold out it's gonna be packed who do
you think is the most famous comedian
that we would know that's going to come
just to watch the show while the most
famous one it's on the phone run yeah
nobody like any audience that are gonna
want to be like oh sure once said they
might come I didn't believe who said
they might come or so they might come
who who Mia
hahaha actually Landsberg who's hitting
myself who said they might cut fair to
say that who's like a famous person that
we might have figs I don't want people
to get all excited you know why if I get
excited we can't buy tickets anyway
that's true they're gone right when are
they all got sales for industry no hunt
we sold a hundred yeah 100 who is one of
the most famous ones who might come that
might not we don't know if arrow start a
little buzz yeah who might lead slow him
out at the studio he says we sold 100
one more time a hundred we didn't we
publicize it just went from word of
mouth so who do you think who do you
think said that they might be there but
we all know people go back like a little
bit sure that's not your father
yeah uh TIG who I I don't know I I'm not
going over any of this this is Bonnie
and Kato do I know it you said yeah you
did say that's what Bobby said sir so
who might show up to this half-empty
flop who do you know Mike I have known
you're asking me stuff I don't know I
didn't go over with you all day
I'm going by what I heard from bond you
would have asked body though no I
wouldn't gentle care I'm just going you
know okay perfect
I like oh boy I think Bonnie and Kate
when he's in the back of the car just
sticking his head between the seats like
hey guys what if you want to do your
micromanaging ass I don't know you
literally tried to take over bodies film
like seven times
are you crazy eventually sort of call
himself a producer so you know I do care
is that the way it happened
well yeah get introduced and I find this
do I produced it I try to challenge
ordinator I did a lot yeah you know but
you know that's what it is when you're
team playing on it yeah you know so I
danced with hilarities bonus money I
just like the news that Club won't have
me back
all right you know scientist my picture
you know what do you got what are you
doing what do you got coming up Oh
just like boom worst diversionary tactic
ever you think you Kevin Hart might show
up at ease in New York I would imagine
he what if he's in the or anything so
maybe was in New York and he was at the
Comedy Cellar he wouldn't show up like
[ __ ] cat he wouldn't walk down the
steps are you recording this thing yeah
take your lighting yeah video video and
no audio yeah we should play a little
bit of the audio on the show we should I
would love that yeah because a lot of
our audience I think will be very very
interested in what happens we'll see
what happens yeah we'd like I mean just
a couple of the lines you know we'll see
yeah what do you save it if one I just
know I said I know I say well who knows
because the industry is going to be
Colin what do you think he's saving it
for gonna field offers well you know
what here's would be for calling mr.
negative points of entry pointing back
at themselves you know you know maybe if
Colin would just take a good look in the
mirror but what I'm saying is all those
Rosie do that Boston I mean how great
they were very funny and none of them
were [ __ ] documented none of them won
one there's some stuff that Patricia's
roast your roast Milo's Barry's roast
none other tomorrow's the Caroline's we
had one for you at Bordeaux you do yes
we did I guarantee it
I trust Jim I think just Carolyn's yeah
me too
yeah I think yeah I think Jim's right
either way oh yeah it wasn't don't
Florentines wasn't filmed then we really
sorry in 2000 yeah but no we didn't film
those because we didn't realize how huge
everybody was gonna get career wife
Sports one I'm joking gay work is [ __ ]
great roasted I said that they were
great what
shut up and you standing should have
been fell darling you don't think
anybody's disappointed that those roads
aren't around for posterity apparently
somebody is yes rich moister let's let
these speaking
he's personally saying what everybody
said like six years ago so that's
annoying
today where was a [ __ ] meeting on this
I'm just sayin I said this forever
everybody said it from those works look
you know you shouldn't be saying it
today like it's some spontaneous I had
it written down in case you came up this
is talking a Syrian refugee crisis you
know a lot of those rows yes yeah I
can't wait do you have any jokes give
any jokes written : yes I have a couple
and I'm going after everybody going
after the guest of honour himself rich
Voss all bet 200 back there are yeah
this is going to be a pull no punches
roast I can't wait is that right I'm
only boy is this might come unglued yeah
it's gonna be crazy [ __ ] I'm having
anxiety
why because you're going to see that
[ __ ] hole empty back tables wide open
hot listen to me
exactly he is he hands wages those he is
he makes Liz put up reserve signs little
reserve signs on the back table images
ever get taken I'm never gonna get taken
off the industries not showing up CIA
would show up if you're not coming
disabled for Lorne Michaels Nora look at
you know welfare I'll tell you oh right
there
because I don't I don't divulge of my
life can we wait until off air he's
going to have enough time just think
you're talking to me yeah he will and
they can't call me honest yeah well big
celebrities coming to this no there are
none there yes there won't be any
including the dais yes we all know we're
flop but we're not we're not saying that
we're big celebrities you're claiming
that you might have either 100 ticket
sales no you're going to have to paper
your roast bring a roast I'm gonna have
Barker's
[Laughter]
okay